[Music]  president obama is settled on a new  campaign slogan you know what it is you  may not know forward that's it yeah  that's gonna forward  well now Mitt Romney's also trying out  new campaign slogans but he's getting  mixed results  take a look I'm offering a real choice a  new beginning  we believe in ourselves our greatest  days are ahead the other guys are  talking about everything but the economy  and I'm gonna talk about nothing I hope  I haven't put any agents down a lot of  ideas if you if you've got a shirt on  assume the guys in the room at least do  and the gals have tops I guess you call  them and allowed to say what I'm not  allowed to say that's pretty important  to me I'm over 30 now there's been a lot  of booing just just the other day I met  a veterinarian  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]